this knight has now fallen in ukraine
what we're going to see during the
course of tonight are the main elements
of the russian forces appearing and
getting ready for battle in kiev and
what we've seen so far are light forces
with some missiles and aircraft in
support and what's arriving this evening
are the tanks the heavy artillery and
the infantry in their armored vehicles
so we need to have a look at what the
battle for cave really means and on this
next map begin to see a city
three times the size of manchester home
to more than 2.8 million people which is
about to be the subject of a major
battle
the russians will hope very much that
they can get their tanks to the
presidential palace probably during the
course of tomorrow
and the dilemma for the attackers is
that if they do this they are going to
have to face stiff ukrainian military
opposition
and the more opposition they face the
more they're going to have to destroy
this city and kill civilians in order to
make their way into the center
the dilemma for the defenders is the
reverse in that if they try and hold the
russians on the outskirts
they'll become a much easier target for
russian artillery and air attack and are
likely to be destroyed quickly and in a
more devastating way
if they allow the russians to penetrate
into the city they'll have to give
ground they'll feel they're surrendering
their city but they will weaken the
russian ability to use their artillery
tanks and air power and they'll increase
the chances for defeating the russians
piecemeal with a thousand attacks at any
one time from a highly mobilized
citizenry
this city is like any modern european
city it has uh wonderful buildings uh
high density population areas
thoroughfares narrow streets there is no
way you can conduct a battle for ukraine
and that sees the capital kiev without
major destruction and that's the dilemma
that we're all facing tonight
but there's more than that if we go back
to a map
we need to understand that the russians
are now at the end
of lines of communication back to their
sources of supply in belarus and russia
that are between 150 and 200 miles long
that means that for these
length of those roads
russian trucks are moving fuel
ammunitions spare parts and
food into the battle zone and that
presents a very rich array of targets
for the ukrainian opposition so the
russians have now not just got to fight
for kiev they've got to secure these
very long lines of communication
the third issue is the battle for the
east which is quite different and on
this next map you can see that what
we're beginning to
understand is president putin's ambition
to carve out territory
that would connect russia
through ukraine to the black sea and
maybe he is considering annexing that
now the challenge is he probably felt
that many of the people in this area
were russian speaking and would welcome
a russian intervention
as we've seen during the course of today
that is that is not the case but the
issue that's coming up over the next few
days is how much
of this
area of eastern ukraine is effectively
annexed by russia
and the fourth thing we need to look at
is one of the consequences of the
fighting is the flow of refugees and
what we're seeing already are people
fleeing mostly western ukraine to arrive
in nato countries
so far we believe around 120 000 have
made that journey and the un
is suggesting that maybe four million
ukrainians will will want to move
so we may particularly if that fight for
kiev becomes as stiff as i've described
it could be we may see millions of
ukrainians
leaving ukraine for nato where they'll
be grateful for the sanctuary and deeply
disappointed at the lack of military
support that they've received so far